[موسيقى]
في غرب اوكرانيا تعيش منطقه كاربات
الجبليه وقراها النائيه حياه قاسيه نشات
ماريا هناك هي ام لتسعه اطفال زوجها
بلومير كان مزارعا ثم تطوع للقتال في
الدونباس واليوم يرقض هنا في هذه المقبره
الصغيره ذهب للقتال رغم انه لم يكن مجبرا
كان له الحق في البقاء مع
لكنه قال ان هذا واجبه وانا فخوره
به والدي بطل عباره مكتوبه على ملابس احد
ابنائه الصغار حزن ماريا واطفالها التسعه
دفع متطوعين كثر للوقوف
بجانبهم بعد بث صور جنازه زوجها على شاشات
التلفزيون قامت جمعيه بجمع 15
ل
الئ مرحبا احضرت ثلاثه اشياء كيف حال
الاولاد سوف يستغرق الامر عاما على الاقل
حتى تحصل ماريا على معاش ارمله فاكراني
غارقه في الحرب تحاول ماريا اخفاء دموعها
وتامل بتحقيق النصر
الاكران يجب انلا تذهب تحيتنا سدا يجب ان
ننتصر قبل ابنائ سن الذهاب للقتال اذا
بقيت على قيد الحياه فهذا بفضل
اطفالي في كل انحاء البلاد تملا شوارع
المدن صور الاف الجنود الذين سقطوا على
الجبهه هذا الصبي الصغير يحاول احتضان
صوره والده الذي توفي اثناء حصار ماريوبول
العام الماضي لم يتبقى لطفله وزوجته سوى
عدد من
الاوسمه
تعلمت خلال العام الماضي ان اعتمد على
نفسي وبدات مساعده الدوله تصل لكني اليوم
اعيش ولا اعلم ما يخبئه لي الغد كانت لدي
خطه لاسرتي المكونه من ثلاثه افراد لكنني
اليوم لا اعرف
المستقبل اما يجينا فتبحث عن معنا في فوضى
هذه الحرب طويله الامد لقد اتخذت قرارها
بعد شهر من وفاه زوجها في الدونباس قامت
بالتطوع كممرضه في المكان الذي كان يقاتل
فيه ابذل قصار جهدي لانقاذ حياه الجنود
وفي اعماقي احصي عدد الرجال الذين انقذتهم
من الموت تخليدا لذكرى زوجي عندما يصاب
رجل بجروح خطيره اقول له ان يفكر بزوجته
لقد مات زوجي دون وجود ممرضه الى جانبه
ارتدي قلادته العسكريه انها بمثابه تعويذه
لي
في طريقها باتجاه الجبهه تفكر بالطبع
بالخطر اليومي الذي يمكن ان
يواجهها لكنها تقرر مواصله طريق زوجها
الجيش الاوكراني لم يسمح لنا بمرافقته الى
الاماكن
الخطره التصرف بشكل عاجل وعلاج الجنود
المصابين في اسرع وقت ممكن هكذا تشارك
يفنا في حرب تامل انلا يخسرها
الاوكراني هل كان زوجي سيدني انا متاكده
من انه سيكون فخورا بي بالطبع سيكون قلقا
لان لدينا ثلاثه اطفال وربما افقد حياتي
ايضا لكن اذا بقينا في منازلنا دون فعل
شيء فسوف نخسر هذه
الحرب لا تزال السلطات الاوكرانيه ترفض
تقديم ايه ارقام رسميه لكن وفقا لبعض
التقديرات الامريكيه قتل ما لا يقل عن 70
الف جندي اوكراني والعديد من العائلات
اليوم في حاله
حداد